Democrats are deeply bothered by the new
CIA revelations that Vladimir Putin
attempted to influence the presidential
election in order to help trump the
right to be upset the notion that one of
the world's worst dictators hacked the
Democratic National Committee in an
attempt to boost a candidate's power
should be kind of trumping but they
haven't typically been upset about such
things in the past when they benefit
Democrats take for example Barack Obama
go all the way back to March 2012 when
Obama met with Putin stooge and then
russian President Dmitry Medvedev Obama
was caught on a live mic telling
Medvedev quote on all these issues but
particularly missile defense this can be
solved but it's important for him to
give me space and Medvedev said yes I
understand and then got a message about
speech space for u2 which Obama said
this is my last election after my
election I have more flexibility and
Medvedev answered gently
I am left stunned I will put on submit
the Vladimir Democrats were fine with
that
in fact he then proceeded to spend the
rest of the election cycle mocking Mitt
Romney for stating the Russia posed the
greatest geopolitical threat to the
United States Obama himself mocked
Romney by saying during a debate quote
the 1980s are now calling that's for
their foreign policy back he then handed
control of Syria to Putin and then he
followed by doing nothing when Russia
invaded Ukraine let's go back a little
bit further in 1983 senator Teddy
Kennedy wanted to run for president so
he sent his friend John Tunney to Moscow
in Moscow Tony told the head of the
Soviet Union Yuri Andropov that he
wanted a deal according to Forbes quote
Kennedy's message was simple he proposed
an unabashed quid pro quo Kennedy would
lend Andropov a hand in dealing with
President Reagan in return the Soviet
leader would lend the Democratic Party a
hand in challenging Reagan in the 1984
presidential election the only real
potential threats to Reagan are problems
of war and peace and soviet-american
relations the memo stated these issues
according to the senator well without a
doubt become the most important of the
election campaign apparently Kennedy
offered to help Andropov get TV
interviews in the US and he offered to
visit Moscow the deal didn't work out
but Democrats ignored the reports when
they finally broke in 2009 or check out
in 1960 here's Craig Shirley and Andrew
Shirley reporting quote in 1960 the
Soviets held u2 pilot Gary Powers after
his plane crashed illegally in Russia
and specifically delayed his release
until after the presidential elections
they used powers as a bargaining chip
and according to Khrushchev himself it
worked in his memoirs the Soviet leaders
stated we kept Nixon from being able to
claim he could deal with the Russians
our ploy made a difference of at least
half a million votes which he had
Kennedy the edge he needed Democrats
complaining about Russian elections
interference are breaking with
historical president it's also worth
noting that so are Republicans who
suddenly don't seem to care about
Russian involvement so long as it
benefits their guy but hypocrisy the
Democrats is certainly on full display
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show all righty so much to talk about
today here on the bench Shapiro show
them you'll get to all of it but first
we have to say hello to our friends over
at nature box nature box.com slash
Shapiro so if you're looking for
healthier snacks around the office
really tasty delicious snacks all the
people around the office I think are
eating it right now the nature box
product is fantastic if you go to nature
box at calm then you can get all sorts
of different options they have
everything from sweets baked treats
things like mini coco Belgian waffles
and whole wheat vanilla animal cookies
to chips pretzels and dips dried fruit
fried dried fruit and fruit juice
they have granola and oatmeal they even
have jerky yeah all the people in the
office really enjoy all the stuff that
we get from at nature box and they have
a hundred snacks to choose from they're
constantly adding delicious new ones and
they taste great and they are better for
you that a lower cal they are free from
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
so you can feel really good about
snacking great office treat particularly
for buying for the whole office and you
just want to stock up on the table
nature box.com slash Shapiro and you get
50% off your first order which is pretty
hefty discount nature box.com
hero okay so over the weekend the big
breaking news of course was that the the
CIA basically suggested that Vladimir
Putin shirtless riding a horse had
decided to hack the US election not that
he hacked the election results but by
hacking the DNC and helping out
WikiLeaks by revealing information about
Hillary Clinton that this had made
Hillary Clinton president now see I
didn't say that the CIA didn't say that
they made Hillary President they said
that was Putin's intent that what Putin
wanted out of life was for Hillary
Clinton not to be President to the
United States he wanted Donald Trump to
be President of the United States here
is the Washington Post's original report
they said quote intelligence agencies
have identified individuals with
connections to the Russian government
who provided WikiLeaks with thousands of
hacked emails from the DNC and others
including Hillary's campaign chairman
according to US officials those
officials described the individuals as
actors
known to the Intel community and part of
a wider Russian operation to boost a
Trump and hurt Clinton's chances NPR
seconded that report now here's the
thing we haven't seen any that
intelligence ourselves right so we can't
really gauge whether this intelligence
is good or bad or whether it's accurate
or not so we have to decide between two
sources the CIA or Donald Trump so
Donald Trump responded it's the Trump
transition team did something that I
think is actually really really stupid
they released this statement and said
these are the same people that said
Saddam Hussein had released weapons of
mass destruction the election ended a
long time ago and one of the biggest
electoral college victories in history
it's now time to move on and make
America great again these are two
separate issues okay two things can be
true once the Russians tried to hack the
DNC in order to help Trump and Trump
would won anyway okay I think Trump
wouldn't won anyway because the fact is
that what actually stopped Trump you
want to look at the news cycle what
actually hurt Trump was not the
WikiLeaks particularly what helped Trump
was not the WikiLeaks particularly it
was the Comey investigation which wasn't
based on the WikiLeaks remember the
Comey investigation was based on
Hillary's email servers and if she
hadn't hidden the emails in the first
place wouldn't been an issue and it was
based on the the fact that he found all
sorts of Hillary emails on Anthony
Weiner's laptop well Anthony Weiner's
laptop wasn't hacked by the Russians so
it really had one didn't have anything
to do it the other also if you look at
the polls what you really see is that
Hillary was wildly unpopular from the
beginning of the election cycle and she
never was able to get out of that funk
she was never able to break out of that
it's not the Russians fault that Hillary
Clinton is the worst presidential
candidate in the history of American
politics you can't blame that one on
shirtless Vladimir Putin that said Trump
statement here has really done because
instead of him just saying look this is
something that I'd be investigated but
we won the election fair and square
there's no evidence that Americans voted
for me because they were persuaded by
Putin's leaks instead of saying that
instead he goes directly at the CIA and
just denies the veracity of the report
which is a really simple minded way of
doing these things it's really dumb
because it was created a rift with the
intelligence agencies who supposedly
he's gonna be relying on to give him
national security updates and that's a
problem first of all him just dumping
out there these are the same people that
said Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction to be accurate the CIA said
the desert I'm Hussein was probably
pursuing weapons of mass destruction
they didn't say 100% certainty Saddam
Hussein has weapons of mass
and also he keeps trotting out this fib
this is the biggest electoral college
victory ever it's not its 44th out of 54
elections so actually it's not a
particularly large electoral college win
none of that matters the bottom line is
that he's created a rift with the Intel
community that's not particularly smart
it's just not particularly smart
Kellyanne Conway kind of knows that it's
smart and so she's on national TV trying
to walk that back saying that no no
you're missing the point Trump actually
likes the intelligence community he
respects the intelligence community he's
going to be pregnant I'm saying he
respects it but he's saying he doesn't
believe their conclusions he's saying
specifically he does not believe the
conclusion of 17 agencies that Russia
was involved in the conclusion that this
helped him win and Hillary Clinton lose
that that's what he said me I heard that
and then she's lying that's not what
Trump said he didn't say that it was
about that first of all the CIA never
said that Putin made hillary clinton
lose they said that that was putin's
intent but they didn't say here's our
elections analysis demonstrating that
this was what cost what what cost
hillary clinton the election cycle it is
gonna be a serious rift here here's what
Trump actually had to say again Trump
has no evidence as far as I'm aware that
what the CIA is saying is wrong that
this was not Putin's intent yeah he has
no again I think that all that happened
here is that Donald Trump doesn't like
the result the CIA's coming up with and
so now he's gonna rip on the CIA whether
you believe the CIA or not is irrelevant
actually all the matters here is that
Donald Trump has no evidence that the
CIA is actually wrong he's just saying
this because he doesn't like the
conclusion which is that Vladimir Putin
was trying to help him out which by the
way was clearly true all the way through
the election cycle okay the fact is
we'll get to this in a second you can
see sort of why Vladimir Putin was
trying to help him out but we'll talk
about that a minute here's what Trump
said about this whole debacle I think
it's ridiculous I think it's just
another excuse I don't believe it I
don't know why and I think it's just you
know they talked about all sorts of
things every week it's another excuse we
had a massive landslide victory as you
know in the electoral college I guess
the final numbers are now at 306 and
she's you know down to a very low number
no I don't believe that at all okay so
that he's right that the Democrats
pushing this is the reason she lost
that's crap but for him to attack the
CIA is really dumb and you can see why
Donald Trump was widely
would want Donald Trump you can't I mean
let's be frank about this this is just
the stuff that Trump said during the
election about what was happening with
with Russia here's here's all of the
stuff that Trump said during the
election I mean it could be Russia but
it could also be China it could also be
lots of other people it also could be
somebody sitting on their bed that
weighs 400 pounds okay
I don't know Putin he said nice things
about me if we got along well that would
be good if Russia and the United States
got along well and went after Isis that
would be good but again he killed
journalists that don't agree with him
well I think our country does plenty of
killing also Joe okay so you can see why
Vladimir Putin might be a little warm
toward this guy cuz clearly Trump is
pretty warm towards him by the way I do
have to say every time we show a
split-screen of Hillary Clinton I'm
immensely relieved that I have to look
at look at her as president of the
United States it's a wonderful thing can
you imagine the horror show that would
be whoa but but here's how the Democrats
react so Democrats can't just here's
thing that Democrats in the media they
cannot just take the story at face value
Vladimir Putin wants Trump to be
President that's probably not good for
the United States it's not good if
Vladimir Putin is one of the worst
dictators on the planet a fellow who
actually has Soviet style of ambitions
right they for that they can't just make
the claim that those people want to
Trump to be President and that's bad and
Trump is catering to those people that
would be a legit criticism instead they
have to turn it into no no Hillary
actually won Hillary actually won if it
hadn't been for Vladimir Putin if she
hadn't been for Putin then Hillary
definitely definitely would have one
here is CNN guests saying that just yes
yesterday bothers hearing you correctly
you're saying we should have another
election how would that work is that
plausible when a foreign country
interferes in your election and the
outcome is endowed and legitimacy of the
government I don't know how it worked
constitutionally I'm not a lawyer
constitutional lawyer but I'm deeply
disturbed by the fact that the Russians
interfered and I would like to see the
evidence because if the evidence is
there I don't see any other way than to
vote again I mean I there's an American
citizen okay this is crazy towns
it's crazy times again there's no
evidence to suggest the Putin National
succeeded and that's what cost Hillary
Clinton the election in fact as an eight
silver points out if Clinton lost the
election because of an event it was
really not having to with Russia is
having to with James Comey of the FBI
revealing information about how the
investigation was still ongoing or had
been reinvigorated like a week and a
half before the election here's Nate
silver the the pollster he said quote
there's more evidence late deciding
voters Brooks strongly against Clinton
in swing states enough to cost her
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania I'll put
it like this Clinton almost certainly
would be president-elect if the election
had been held October 27th the day
before the Comey letter and that's
probably right but again that has to do
at the Comey letter it doesn't have to
do it the Putin hacks but the entire
left is taking it as though Putin made
Trump president which is absolute
nonsense there's no evidence for that
here's a time editor Michael Duffy and
he's making a different argument he's
suggesting that what's really going on
here is that the Russians could be
blackmailing Trump which again no
evidence of this we know from the
campaign John that democratic emails
were vacuumed up and leaked we don't
know exactly how much was vacuumed up
from the Republican emails but we now
know from the intelligence reports about
the intelligence community's assessment
that they also got Republican emails
which means someone in if that's true
and of course the RNC has denied this
but if it's true and it stands to reason
that it may be true and someone in
Moscow or in Russia is holding on to all
of those emails do and those effect not
Hillary Clinton but Donald Trump
presumably as he steps into the role of
President so whatever force in the City
of Russia that is in control of this
information or this it now stands in a
position to exert some leverage if it is
true over the future president okay so
again there's no evidence of this but
the Democrats have to keep pushing and
pushing and pushing Claire McCaskill the
senator from Missouri she says that this
Russian election interference is a form
of warfare he's in pretty extreme
language here how about this issue of
Russian involvement American election we
saw these reports over the weekend we've
been talking about them with the CIA
saying they were trying to tip the
scales for Donald Trump you've now got
these bipartisan calls for an
investigation you support that yeah
absolutely and by the way this should be
not only about protecting us going
forward but this is a form of warfare
for Vladimir Putin who is a thug and a
bully
has the friends around the globe that we
don't want to be friends with for him to
be trying to impact our elections that
we have to there has to be he has to be
held accountable yeah that's why this
has to well that's that's some of that's
classified I believe and I don't think
it's something that we can discuss on TV
but I've had briefings just this last
week that indicate that this is a very
serious issue for the American people to
understand and for Donald Trump to
dismiss out of hand the intelligence
community's fact gathering is frankly
doesn't bode well for him protecting our
country okay so this is all you know
it's funny to watch Democrats suddenly
hot and bothered about Russia as I said
earlier the Democrats didn't care about
Russia when it was Barack Obama doing
the doing the catering here was the the
incident I mentioned earlier Barack
Obama Dmitry Medvedev caught in a hot
mic Obama offering flexibility to Russia
in return for their help in the 2012
election
not about this okay so again it is
amazing for the Democrats how they are
perfectly willing have Russia intervene
in our election so long as it's
Democrats who are working with the
Russians if it were Trump working with
the Russians it's the end of the world
now the Trump makes this point by the
way and he makes it exactly right he
tweeted out earlier today and this is
100% true about this here's what he
tweeted this is the there we go can you
imagine if the election results were the
opposite and we tried to play the rush
of CIA card it would be called a
conspiracy theory that of course is 100%
true if he tried to do that
everybody would call it a conspiracy
theory and say it was nonsense now the
entire media are pushing that conspiracy
theory it's still nonsense there's no
evidence to suggest that Russia is what
won this election for Donald Trump they
were trying to help that is probably
true they probably hacked the DNC that
is probably true but they did the idea
that they order the deciding factor
rather than the American people
rejecting Hillary Clinton I haven't seen
evidence of that at all now one of the
things that has happened here is that
people like me or Republicans
conservatives we look at the Democrats
and we laugh at them because these are
the same people who were saying about
Mitt Romney in 2012 that crazy Mitt
Romney a crazy Romney guy talking about
Russia like it's all threatening and
stuff that crazy Romney fella and now
here they are saying all the Russians
those evil Russians we've got to stop
the evil Russians they're the ones who
are screwing us the Russians and so we
say yeah you're hypocrites
okay the hypocrisy argument works both
ways if you were really bothered about
the Russians in 2012 but now you're
totally fine with Russia intervening in
our elections let me recommend to you
that you take a look at something called
basic intellectual honesty if your gauge
on the left or the right if your gauge
is good for Trump is or bad for Trump is
the only thing that matters if you're on
the left and you're only gauge of
whether something is positive is whether
it is bad for Trump let me suggest to
you that you have no moral Center
because it turns out Trump takes a lot
of variety positions on a lot of
different issues and he switches those
positions frequently and so just because
it's bad for Trump doesn't mean that
it's good for the country if you're on
the left and if you think that you need
a different moral Center and if you're
on the right just as good for Trump
doesn't mean it's good for the country
okay just because the Russians helped
out Trump this time doesn't mean the
Russians are our friends or that this is
a good thing or that this is something
that we should that we should be excited
as the Russians trying to intervene an
American election it's not something
that's positive foreign countries
hacking into American institutions and
getting involved is not a is not a good
thing for the United States listen we
complained about when Obama did it to
Israel certainly we should complain
about it when the Russians do it to us
even if the outcome is something that we
would prefer I have to say hello to our
friends over at trunk club comm trunk
club this is if you've noticed that I've
upgraded my wardrobe in the in the last
few months that's because I've been
using front club if not then you just
have terrible taste in clothes but trunk
Club calm is the place to go if you're
interested in getting top-notch brands
and also more importantly you actually
get to work with a stylist so what you
do is you you use their their service
you go to trunk club comm slash Ben and
they hook you up with a stylist the
stylist tells you what kind of clothes
are good for you you used to say what
kind of clothes you want and they take
all your measurements and then they send
you the clothes in a box and you can
either pick them you can choose to keep
them or you can send them back to them
for no charge and it really is fantastic
and a bunch of major cities like Dallas
New York LA Chicago DC Charleston you
actually go into one of their centers
and they'll actually have a stylist sit
with you and go through the clothes
you're looking for and they have some
warehouses full of clothes where they
can they can try things on you they have
tailoring on the premises you can even
send stuff to them to tailor it for a
small fee they're really it can be your
one-stop shop for clothes and better you
should own a few pairs of really nice
clothes then that you should get a bunch
of crap from from the local from the
local store that's gonna wear you wear
out and not look very good they're back
by Nordstrom stylist have access to some
of the best designer brands in the
country go to trunk club.com slash been
trunk clubs comm slash been there
opening a new factory I think in Boston
and and they are really professional
they're really great I've worked with
one of their stylists to get nice pair
of jeans and also I got a jacket Spenser
my own money actually because I think
they're for the clothes that they they
put out there are really really nice the
clothes the day that they sell to you
are really great I got this really nice
khaki jacket that you may see any night
on making Kelly show but it's from club
comm / Ben go there check it out great
service trunk club okay so the so as I
say if your soul gage of decency is
whether it helps Trump or not then you
need a different moral Center you need a
different moral Center
and you're seeing Republicans react in a
couple of different ways you're seeing a
lot of Republicans who are close to the
Trump team basically saying we're gonna
pretend that Vladimir Putin doesn't
exist or that he's a nice guy and that
he's sexy with his shirt off because he
helped our boy Jason Miller is a
spokesperson for Trump for the Trump
campaign he came out and he said this he
said what this is is an attempt to
delegitimize president select strumpets
win so there's talk of a bipartisan
probe of the Russian hacking it was an
attempt to deal legitimize president
elect Trump's win or maybe it's just an
attempt to look into the fact that we
need to strengthen our institutions so
that the Russians can't hack us and then
reveal information it's all fun and
games gang until it turns out that
Vladimir Putin decides that he's going
to use the power of the hack against
people that we like right what happens
when Donald Trump decides to cross
Vladimir Putin over some issue and next
thing you know Vladimir Putin has had
his his lackeys hack into Trump's email
and you're getting and you're getting
the French porn tape people were talking
about this entire election cycle right
well what happens when all that happens
it's nothing good Chuck Todd was it was
done with Reince Priebus and Ryan's was
doing his usual Schilling routine here
as here's Rhines pretending that nothing
is happening with Vladimir Putin
everything's great with Vladimir Putin
do you believe let's just clear this up
do you believe does the president-elect
believe that Russia was trying to muddy
up and get involved in the election in
2016 number one you don't know it I
don't know it and there's been no
conclusive or specific report to say
otherwise so that's the first thing the
second thing I would tell you is that
you don't have any proof that the
outcome of the election was changed
people forget about who did the hacking
do you want to know even if someone did
the hacking is no does he what to a
notice if ik the source we want to know
so there's going to be an investigation
he wants an investigation on Capitol
Hill
of course listen I don't know what
investigations he wants but yes we do
want to know but what I don't want to do
Chuck is have a debate with you over an
unnamed source that the article said was
inconclusive over who hacked and why
they hacked look someone hacked we don't
like that I don't like it no one wants
it we want to protect American interest
its America first I don't want the DNC
hacked
I don't want anybody hacked but I don't
know who did
hacking that's my point investigation
then why do you oppose an investigation
why is Jason Miller out there saying
that there shouldn't be any
investigation you just say you want to
know but they don't want investigation
intellectually dishonest and I'm gonna
call it out when it is intellectually
dishonest if the left is being
intellectually dishonest because
suddenly they care the rush is getting
involved in our elections and they were
fine with it in 2012 I'll call that out
and when the right which opposed
Vladimir Putin's dictatorial nonsense
for literally my entire life now comes
out and says well you know we don't
really care whether they're hacking or
if they are hacking maybe she's a
400-pound guy sure there were 17
different reports from intelligence
agencies suggesting Russian involvement
in the hacks but you know no need for an
investigation let's not jump the gun
it's just it's it's utter it's utter
foolishness and that's that's a problem
for me well we'll talk more about this
plus more breaking news on Trump
Secretary of State and Trump did a big
interview over the weekend and will talk
about some of the things that he said
and so we'll get things I like in things
I hate so much more coming up over its
daily wired.com go over there check it
out subscribe $8 a month gets you a
subscription is a Lee Weyer com is again
the annual subscription you get a signed
copy of my book true allegiance I think
that that deals gonna expire pretty soon
so you want to go over there and check
it out now plus we have a store that's
gonna be opening up in the next few
weeks with gear and you got big
discounts on that we have lots of good
stuff coming at daily wire.com you get
to be part of the mailbag on thursdays
and as i say lots of goodies coming that
i can't wait to tell you about as time
progresses to go over there and
subscribe daily wire.com and become part
of the largest conservative podcast on
the interwebs
[Music]
you